big news of the day is another horrific
mass shooting at this time
in colorado where 10 people were killed
at a colorado supermarket according to
the associated press
a shooting at a colorado supermarket
killed 10 people on monday including a
police officer who was the first to
respond to the scene
according to authorities police arrested
a suspect they didn't reveal his name or
any details about the shooting
at an evening news conference where
boulder police chief maris harold fought
back tears
investigators had just begun sorting
through evidence and witness interviews
and didn't have details on a motive for
the shooting
at the king supers at store in boulder
which is about 25 miles northwest of
denver home to the university of
colorado according to boulder county
district attorney
michael doherty he said this is a
tragedy and a nightmare for boulder
county these were people going about
their day doing their shopping i promise
the victims and the people of the state
of colorado we will
secure justice the attack was according
to the associated press
the seventh mass killing this year in
the united states following the march
16th shooting that left eight people
dead at three atlanta area
area massage businesses according to a
database compiled by the associated
press usa today
and northwestern university and of
course it all depends on how you define
mass shooting because some definitions
are like three people or more some
definitions are five people or more it
follows a lull in mass killings during
the pandemic in 2020 which had the
smallest number of such attacks in more
than a decade which is mainly because
people were locked inside their houses
so people couldn't congregate which
meant it was more difficult to pull off
a mass shooting this database tracks
mass killings defined as four
or more dead not including the shooter
one of the reasons by the way that a lot
of these
statistical databases like to separate
off mass shootings with four or more
dead is because if they include three or
more dead
then the numbers rise dramatically and
the racial composition of the shooters
goes
dramatically differently because it
turns out there are a lot of gangland
shootings that involve
people who are killing two three people
and so the numbers change pretty
radically you'll notice that mass
shootings are always the excuse for gun
control but the deadly violence that
happens in chicago every single weekend
that is never the excuse
for gun control because again this plays
into the broader media narrative which
is that the big problem in america
is white supremacy and america's systems
of violence
the slain officer was identified as eric
talley51 who'd been with boulder police
since 2010 according to herald he went
to the store after a call about shots
fired someone carrying a rifle
he was by all accounts one of the
outstanding officers of the boulder
police department his life was cut too
short already said
of tally identities of the other nine
victims were not disclosed monday night
as police were still notifying
their family members matthew kirsch
acting u.s attorney for colorado pledged
the full weight of federal law
enforcement
to support the investigation officers
did escort a shirtless man with blood
running down his leg out of the store in
handcuffs
authorities would not say if he was in
fact the suspect
officials have not said whether the
suspect is the person who was taken from
the shooting scenes at foothills
hospital
in boulder in the hospital is not
releasing any more information dean
schiller told the ap
he had just left the supermarket when he
heard gunshots and saw three people
lying face down two in the parking lot
one near the doorway
he said he couldn't tell if they were
breathing there was also video live
streamed on youtube
which showed one person on the floor
inside the store and two more outside on
the ground
and you can stay on you can hear
gunshots at the beginning of the video
at one point authorities said over the
loudspeaker the building was surrounded
and you need to surrender
sarah moonshadow told the denver post
two shots rang out just after she and
her son
nicholas edwards have finished buying
strawberries she said she told her son
to get down
and then we just ran it's obviously just
another
horrific mass shooting and the media
typically
in these situations responds by
suggesting of course
that people who don't agree with their
basic policy prescriptions are somehow
unsympathetic
to the victims in these sorts of
situations because
you know that the next political move
here forever and always will be a
federal call for gun control
joe biden has been looking for an excuse
to push gun control for a little while
here now
he's been talking about gun control
consistently for the last 10 15 years
he used to be somebody who's a little
looser on gun control now he is somebody
who's much tighter on gun control he's
been pushing for an assault weapons ban
i'll of the 1994 assault weapons ban
that really had no impact on mass
shootings in the united states he's been
looking for that
for quite a while so this will be used
politically as a
as a hook in order to push forward
the gun control agenda and the media are
going to foster this by suggesting of
course
that if you don't agree with joe biden's
agenda it's because you don't care about
the people who were killed
it's a cheap political trick that is
played during every tragedy
that if you don't agree with my policy
prescription it's because you don't care
about
the people who have died or the people
who've been victimized in any particular
way
you can see the media already ramping up
for this right that if you say
that the gun control measures that are
likely to be pushed by the federal
government
are extraordinarily unlikely to prevent
mass shootings in fact virtually
every gun control policy that's been
pushed by the federal government has had
no
impact on mass shootings the number of
guns in circulation in the united states
has risen dramatically over the course
of the last 15 to 20 years
the number of people who have been
killed in mass shootings year on year
has actually been going down
but that does not matter to the to the
folks
who who push gun control and so their
idea is you are unsympathetic to victims
this has been a thing ever since i told
piers morgan not to do it on cnn
the reality is that you can be deeply
sympathetic to people who have been
harmed in any sort of crime
and still recognize that that
bad policy does not solve the problem
okay but you can see that the media
already sending the predicate so here on
cnn was one of the reporters
saying that this is just the way america
is this is just it's unique to america
this is how america is now
realistically speaking america does have
more
absolute numbers of mass shootings than
other countries but there are mass
shootings in australia they've been mass
shootings in norway if you were to look
at the number of deaths per million
from mass shootings it's actually higher
in some civilized countries than it is
in the united states
nonetheless again the predicate here is
that america is unique
that this problem is easily solved by a
simple policy change which of course it
is not
and the media are going to suggest that
if you oppose that policy change it's
because you don't care about what just
happened in boulder colorado here was
cnn
jumping on that within probably an hour
of the shooting breaking
a larger story here that may not be
addressed today but is a
is one that we have to address in light
of what happened uh in atlanta which is
are we
facing a spring and summer of uh you
know mass casualty events
uh as we come out as people congregate
uh and that is something that the biden
white house will have to address as well
juliette how can that be how can it be
that after a year
of basic quarantine in the country the
first thing we do
as americans is go back to mass
shootings i mean how can that be
okay so again the the level of of
incredulity i believe it's allison
camerata over on cnn
the level of incredulity there the the
notion that you are
how can it be that we as americans are
going we as americans aren't doing
anything
i didn't shoot anyone today did you i
didn't engage in a mass shooting
in fact as of yesterday as far as i'm
aware there were some 330 million
americans who didn't
engage in a mass shooting it's not as
though everybody went out in the streets
and started shooting guns in the air and
then turned the guns on their fellow
citizens
there are 300 million guns in the united
states there are over 100 million long
guns in the united states
okay virtually none of them were used in
a mass shooting yesterday
but there was one used by somebody who
was evil we don't know his name yet we
don't know his motive yet
okay so we have no insight into why this
we have no insight into how the gun was
obtained we just don't have any
information as of yet that has not
stopped the media from immediately
setting
the emotional groundwork for a gun
control push and again the emotional
ground work is that this is the norm in
america this is what's regular
and most americans are fine with it most
americans just turn a blind eye casey
hunt
at nbc news pushing the same sort of
idea which is the capital hill
correspondent she tweeted out we're all
emotionally exhausted after the last
year we've lost so much and so many but
i refuse to let exhaustion help
normalize 10 people getting shot and
killed as they go about their daily
lives for any or no reason
we have a moral imperative to be better
than this i don't even know what that
last part means
a moral imperative to be better than
what nobody is saying
that what happened in colorado is decent
good or should be something that we
ignore
right who is saying that better than
what did you engage in a mass shooting
yesterday i didn't
okay this notion that all americans are
somehow
okay or blase about 10 fellow americans
being shot to death in a supermarket
including a police officer and some
other blase about that
we can't just go back to our normal i
don't believe that casey hunt is more
sympathetic than you are
or than i am i don't believe that casey
hunt is a a deeper wellspring
of emotion than you are or than other
normal americans are i think all
americans
are rightly outraged at the act of evil
that we saw yesterday in boulder
colorado
but again the media are setting the
groundwork and the groundwork is that
when joe biden comes out and makes an
emotional pitch for gun control
if you don't believe that that gun
control is
is truly well calibrated toward reducing
risk and preserving rights
then this means that you just don't care
right you're not better than this in the
words of casey hunt
right you're you shouldn't normalize no
nobody's normalizing anything
but this is the same game that our media
play and it really is kind of an
emotionally manipulative game that if
you don't agree with what they want
it means you're a bad person that is the
subtle argument that is being made here
it's not a particularly subtle argument
in reality some people are less subtle
even than that mary l trump who is
famous only because her last name is
trump and has made a bajillion dollars
off of writing
a book about how much she doesn't like
donald trump so mary l trump tweeted out
the nra is a terrorist organization and
should be treated as such do we have any
evidence
that this particular person was an nra
member or that the nra fostered his
behavior or that the nra trained him for
this behavior
and by the way what exactly is that
suggestion if the nra's a terrorist
organization then presumably we should
round up all the members and put them in
gitmo
if the nr is a terrorist organization
well we're going to go around does joe
biden have the capacity to just drone
american citizens
who happen to believe in the second
amendment
so little of this is rooted in anything
remotely resembling a policy debate
that if you want to make a case for
specific
pieces of legislation that would
mitigate
mass shootings or shootings at all well
actually preserving americans
fundamental right to defend themselves
and defend their property and defend
their rights
then bring it forth but this is the big
barack obama used to admit this all the
time he used to say
sure the sure legislation we're not
bringing forward on gun control wouldn't
stop this shooting
but it might stop other shootings might
okay well if it wouldn't stop this
shooting then why are you talking about
this piece of legislation on the back of
this particular
act of evil they recognize the game
before it's being played because i
promise you this is going to be the
narrative over the course of the next
couple of weeks as joe biden immediately
shifts
into gun control mode he's immediately
going to shift into gun control mode the
media are going to shift along with him
because they don't want to talk about
what's happening on the border because
that of course is a biden fostered
crisis and so they're immediately going
to shift with joe biden into gun control
talk
and the implication is going to be those
evil obstructionist republicans
if only they would just go along with
the gun control agenda
then all of this would stop and if they
don't go along with it it's because they
wish to normalize in the words of casey
hunt what just happened in colorado
again no one is normalizing acts of evil
that is not something that any fellow
american is doing and if you are
imputing to fellow americans that they
literally don't care about people
getting shot in a supermarket in
colorado we shouldn't share the same
country
if you truly believe that your fellow
americans
do not care about innocents being gunned
down in a supermarket then you're living
next to people who are evil
and you shouldn't be sharing a town with
them you shouldn't be sharing a church
with them you shouldn't be sharing a
country with them
but that is the underlying emotional
play that is being made here by your
delightful
mainstream media i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the ben shapiro show if you
did go ahead and hit the subscribe
button so you stay up to date on all of
our future content